-Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks.
It's great to be here.
I grew up in New York City
and I went to college here, too.
I went to Juilliard.
I played the viola.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you don't know
what a viola is, I'll tell you
It's like a violin
but a little bigger
and nobody cares.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
I like telling people
I went to Juilliard
because they act impressed
and then I act modest...
[ Light laughter ]
...and I love that.
They're like, "Whoa, Juilliard."
I'm like, "Eh, it's nothing.
They're like,
"Wow, humble and talented.
I'm like, "Yes."
[ Laughter ]
"I am perfect."
It's annoying when sometimes
someone hasn't heard
of Juilliard.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause then I just have
to politely explain to the
that it's a big deal.
[ Laughter ]
They're like,
"Oh, what's Juilliard?"
I'm like,
"Oh, it's just, you know,
one of the best music schools.
They're like, "Oh, music?
My niece plays violin."
I'm like,
"Yeah, she wouldn't get in."
[ Laughter and applause ]
When I was 9,
I went to soccer camp,
and that was a nightmare
'cause I was bad at sports
And I knew
I was particularly bad,
because at the camp,
everyone would call me
a "good sport."
[ Light laughter ]
That's where you're
just so used to losing
and it gets mistaken
for a good attitude.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Well, we lost again."
The coach is like,
"This kid gets it."
[ Laughter ]
But I'm competitive,
and I liked being called
a good anything.
So, "good sport,"
I was like, "All right.
I will be the best sport."
[ Laughter ]
And at the end of the summer
they gave out these awards
And they announced
the sportsmanship award.
And I was fully expecting
to get this, and I didn't.
Some other loser did.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, this quiet gir
named Jenny had been muttering
"Good game" the whole summer
[ Laughter ]
I went up to her after.
I was like,
"Hey, congratulations."
She was like,
"You should've gotten it."
I was like,
"Oh, you're good, Jenny."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jenny...
[ Scoffs ]
I was with my friend recently,
and she said something
kind of weird to me.
She was like, "Isabel,
you have resting sad face.
[ Light laughter ]
I was like, "Oh, no.
It's active."
[ Laughter ]
I don't smile a lot
in my everyday life.
I have kind of a goofy smile
I get self-conscious.
But it's fun
when I get that cat call, like
"Hey, baby, smile."
"Okay." [ Growls ]
They're like, "Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
I have been sad.
I recently
went through a break-up.
And I'm scared
to fall in love again now
because here's what I learne
about love, all right?
Love is the only thing that,
when you lose it,
you doubt it ever existed
in the first place.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
No one ever loses their keys
and they're like,
"Well, maybe
there never were any keys.
I don't even know."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Maybe I've just been
letting myself in with lies.
[ Laughter ]
I've been trying
to get out of the house more
I was in a coffee shop recently,
and I saw a mother
with her baby.
And I went up to them,
and I was like, "Excuse me
She's so cute."
And the mom said, "Thank you,"
taking the compliment
for the baby.
[ Laughter ]
That made me think,
"I wish I had my mom with me
to take all the compliment
I receive in public today.
[ Light laughter ]
That'd be nice.
Some guy walks by me, he's like,
"Damn, she's sexy."
My mom's like, "Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
"Isabel, the nice man
wants to bang you.
Say thank you."
[ Laughter ]
I love my mom.
I do.
We have a good relationship.
My mom recently informed me that
I breastfed till I was 3.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Yeah, Mom, I remember."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I was in preschool, yeah.
Kids would be like,
"You wanna trade lunches?"
I was like, "My mom just left.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Thank you!
I'm Isabel Hagen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-I have to fist-bump you.
I can't shake hands.
Isabel Hagen!
Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
For more,
go to isabelhagen.com.